juegos en medio de una burbuja
beijing ultima detalles para las justas
olímpicas de invierno bajo el esquema de
reducir al máximo el contacto entre los
participantes y la población local son
más de 2.000 atletas acompañados de
otras 25.000 personas que están
arribando a la capital china en medio de
preocupaciones por el aumento de casos
en el país
ciudades como youssou sean show y sean
aplican confinamientos tras la detección
de casos positivos de ccoo y 19 si eres
la que mayor preocupación ha generado en
las últimas semanas con contagios que
llegaron a superar los 150 mil al día a
finales de diciembre números que no se
veían desde el comienzo de la pandemia
ahora las autoridades sanitarias
aseguran que la situación está
básicamente bajo control hicieron donde
la tendencia dominante de la epidemia se
está mostrando a la baja algo que ha
demostrado ser el resultado en la
prevención temprana y las medidas de
control hoy un conjunto da con un
yangtsé el presidente chimpín estuvo
visitando el martes las instalaciones de
los juegos olímpicos' un evento marcado
por las críticas contra su gobierno por
la situación de derechos humanos países
como eeuu o reino unido han aplicado un
boicot diplomático los organizadores sin
embargo y aplauden que todo marche según
lo planeado
[Música]
estoy muy honrada de poder contarles que
después de nuestra meticulosa
preparación de seis años todos los
trabajos para los juegos de invierno
beijing 2022 están ahora listos
la organización de los juegos sigue su
camino pero hay un contexto distinto en
la ciudad de harbín que acoge el
tradicional festival de esculturas de
hielo y nieve este año al igual que en
2021 se cancelaron varios eventos de la
agenda para evitar la propagación de
nuevo coronavirus